Hello, everybody,
My name is Markiplier
and Welcome to
egh du well it's
um
it's not a let's play
it's a vlog
so
that's cool...
Chica! Make this... *Patting markilegs*
make this intro  *markipatting*
more/less awkward *MARKPLSSTOP*
*weird markiplier sound*
Ueh! Eh, uh-oh..
Dad put Meh down
Y u du dis Dad
I am older den univers dad
rotating dog mode
I hold more power then savage wof
Mark: Brooootating
Chica: dad you try my patience
Mark: Broooootating!
Chica: silly weak dad using too
much energys to change my direction
Mark: Chica, just stay right there *pats her floof*
Chica: dad. i will fite you stop that
Mark: Be my little bubbernut
Chica: Dad, I am not "bubbernut" I am DUG
*markisniff*
Mark: And uh
Chica: I fear for your future dad
Mark: help me make this intro less awkward!
Chica: it became akward since you were here dad
Mark: HUELLO EVERYBODY!
Chica: dad, I can destroy this house with a simple bark. put me down plez
*mating call of the rare and handsome mark*
Mark: Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
Chica: dad, no females will come, you are barren this season, but hopefully next season there will be some
Mark: and welcome to the vlog!
Chica: dad. I will borf this house into the 6th dimension if you do nut put me down
Mark: I guess...
Chica: hnnngggg
Mark: Here's a DOG!!
Chica: I am no mere dug, I am CHICA,
MASTER OF THE ARCANE WOFS
I guess...
*markismooch* one of these days, dad
*markibarks* Daaad, wat are u doin, makin a fool of yourself, no wonder there were no females this season
*makes dog sounds*
CHICA: dad, plz staph
Okay.. alright then..
*markiturtle orgasm noises* thank u human
Mark: Bike! (?????)
Chica: i will spare you today father
Okay,
Mark: Bye pup! Go lay down.
Chica: it's not "laying down"
it's meditating to gain my arcane strength
Oookay
so helloo, it has been a while *41.4 seconds to be exact*
Oh, Chica, you're back.
But you know I'm, I'm not gonna pick you up again, it's okay.
You go lay down, go be good.
She's right there
So it's been awhile
literally since the 20th of April 'till about two days ago
I've been travelling.
uhhh
*herb lore* *markicough*
And that's a long time
It's almost 3 weeks straight *slight voice crack* that I've been travelling
and its been making me slowly lose my mind (Chica: dad that happened a long time ago)
and I've been away from Chica for a long long time
but it's cool! We're back now,
I did come back for like a few days
that's why I picked her up and then.. had to immediately say goodbye again which was horrible
But anyway.
Soo it's been... a LOT of travelling
and *markistumble* just to go on this trip
I had to prerecord like 30..? Oh.. like.. no wait-
I had to prerecord like 50 something videos
which is why the order
the videos have been coming out have been a little strange
intermixed with current day stuff,
inter-spliced with old stuff,
uhmmmm, so I apologize
if it's been confusing and inconsistent but
I'm back now.
*looks at pup*
Chica, stop breathing so loudly! (Chica: don't tell me what to do dad)
*points the finger* Go lay down
Don't give me that look!
It's an adorable look, but it's not gonna work on me
even though it works on me all day, every time
So anyway, it's been a while and I haven't
been able to make a vlog or a Reading Your Comments
in a long time and I was actually
thinking about that, uh, between
vlogs and Reading Your Comments because
it used to be that I made a vlog every Monday
just to talk with you guys and then I tried to start
making Reading Your Comments every Monday
because I like hearing from you guys,
but then it became like a debate between the two! Uh-
Do I vlog? Or do I do Reading Your Comments?
I wanna talk to you guys
but I also wanna hear you guys
so it became like this conundrum
of which one do I do on a monday
and I reached the conclusion
that I'm probably just gonna do both
*fans cheer with delight!*
It may not come out every week but
*fans cheer in disappointment*
I do wanna have the opportunity to talk to you guys
and then I also wanna make Reading Your Comments
because they're really fun and I like
to make them entertaining for you guys so
expect both, I dont know if they're both
gonna be on a monday, maybe one is gonna be on monday
later in the week, but just to be fair to you guys
I'm gonna do both *markispit* so
don't even worry about debating
between the two.
I just spat something!
Something shot out of my mouth, I have no idea what.
So, all in all, I have a lot to tell you guys
about, uh, I'll try to keep it relatively
short. PAX was amazing
I got to see my friends again, obviously
that was good. Uh, Bob wasn't there
because he is now done with law school
which is frickin' fantastic, because
that means that hopefully he (Bob) and Wade and, uh,
maybe even Jack and some other guys
will be able to visit me here in LA!
*sad tone* which would be nice 'cuz the
crushing loneliness *Chica noises* is getting
to me; god damnit. A congratulations to
him, and it was really fun to hang out with the other
guys while I was in PAX.
uh, Boston I, and then
after that, I went back to Cincinnati for
a lil' bit, and then I took this awesome
trip to New York where I got to hang out with
Jack and Felix and a whole slew of other YouTubers.
Like, a whole bunch, and
I could tell, like
*short laugh*
there are so many stories from being there,
that I, I could fill an entire video
with just what happened in New York.
Basically,
we were there just to, uh, celebrate
being YouTubers and
It was a big thing made by Youtube
to get some of its quote-unquote
"Top Creators"
And I'm only quoting that cuz' I was there!
Why the hell am I included in the "Top Creator" bunch?
*looks at 12M subscribers*
I have no idea.
*the humble markimoo in its natural habitat*
Um, but- uh, it-
It was just cool to all be in one place
and be able to talk with each other and
Y'know, hang out! And do activities!
And listen to speakers.
And then, generally just have a good time
with each other..
And it was great!
Because, I went last year to the same thing.
I, uh- It was the creator summit in New York and-
It inspired me.
A-and that was the most important thing that came out of it
is that I was very inspired because
last year, early on in the year
like I-I had a rough time
With the breakup i had with the last relationship
and then
Of course the various things that happened
with me and the hospital and
obviously Daniel a-and so
last year was
a combination of struggling times
but
This creator summit reminded me
Of why I did youtube
and why I do youtube? a-and what its like
not just to be a youtuber
but also to be inspired to push myself
to be better and uh
that's something i touched on in the last vlog
a-an-and it's something that still rings true
In my heart like and this stuff
that i do here "this stuff" uh
the videos that i make are
a source of creative... uh
It's an outlet for my creativity
and its a way that i can channel
what I wanna make
for you guys!
to enjoy... so I-I
always come out of these events and
I get to meet some new people and I get
to meet some youtubers like uh Ethan from H3h3
and uh I get to see Johnatron again
and uh whole bunch of other creators that
I-I I won't even try to remember the names of-
uh but they all are really cool guys
in my mind and... What was I saying?
Man I got- I got sidetracked-
I always [Marki babble] this always happens
I get so sidetracked all the time
When Im trying to talk- I've got a million thoughts
racing through my mind about
What happened in New York and
trying to touch all the subjects and
think about a time and I just wondering how i
can do this... [Orrahh!]
To summarize meeting these cool people
and other Youtubers that I work with
and also getting back in touch with
me watching Youtubers
and being inspired by them
just through them entertaining me
and that's not saying i have high standards of entertainment
i have very low standards of entertainment
umm but just seeing
all these cool creators in one place is really really
*deep breath* motivational
and it helps me push forward in
what i create and it always reminds me
of what i need to do. umm
but as far as stories from there
i mentioned it in ah the last video
that i did but i'll show it to you guys
again
Rachel Ray
gave me this trophy
because i make an incredible Margarita
and here's my secret
to  Margarita success
is a Margarita
is already simplistic
and good you
don't need to add a lot of zest to it
you just need to make one and then
garnish it because presentation
is 50% of everything that's
my only claim to
impressing Rachel Ray but i'm gonna
cherish this statue because
everyone that sees me
with this trophy
wonders why the hell i brought
the trophy to wherever i went
literally after i won this
i took it to every "bar"
and every restaurant and even the
club afterwards and i was dancing
on the dance floor all by myself
because who the hell woulda dance with me
*Looks down at comment section*
i'm the crazy guy with the taco trophy
but they talk to me
probably because of my
success and not who i was
they didn't know who i was
which is probably for the best
i'm the crazy taco guy
hahahaha
and Jack's team won the best flavoured taco
so congratulations to them
*comes closer* he didn't do a whole lot
he just picked the ingredients don't read too much
into it HA HA HA ok i'm gonna
stop embarrassing myself um
so just in general its just good to be
back and its good to be able to make videos again
on time
not that they've been on time but you know in a
timely manner i've been just very running out of videos
and i have to catch up today's my big
recording day where i catch up on
everything *inhales* um oh and i
almost forgot i am
going to be in a comic book which is really
weird i'm actually gonna have a whole comic
uh s- mini series
featured about me uh involving
uh other characters from this company called uh
Red Giant they make a whole bunch of comics
and uh i me and my brother
both are associated with this
uh company because we've been going to
Comic-con San Diego every
year for the past 4-5 years
with them, uh they've been very good to me and
they're actually making a comic about me
and here's the cover
of one of 'em
and.. stuff
So if you wanna see this you can actually get it
through the link in the description below.
In fact
uh the link is to a box
that will get you a special limited edition
foil cover of it (?)
something like that (?)
So there's a link in the description
below check it out if you like.
Uh and
I'll be going to Comic Con again this year so
if you're going , HEY I'll probably see you
there, but the next convention that I'm going to is
actually going to be VID CON
in June, so I'll see you there as well.
So thank you everybody so much for being
patient with me. Thank you for
uh.. watching the stuff that I've made.
and I apologize if..if some of it
was a bit repetitive because
I literally ran out of time
before I left and I've been
um.. doing my best but
now that i'm back I'mma be working with Ryan and
Matt again. We're gonna make some sketches
for you we're gonna be making some new stuff
that will surprise you and uh
one of the big things that I wanna make
very soon is a music
video, like I really wanna make a
music video for you guys because that was something
uh that Cyndago did and
it's something that I've always wanted to
try so, I"M GONNA DO THAT.
I'm gonna 'sing' in it and we'll see
how it goes. So thank you everybody so much
for watching. I look forward to the videos that I'm gonna
be making because I am
Incredibly inspired and I'm always
inspired by what you guys say
to me and what I see from other creators
just the whole big community of
YouTube and having it presented
in front of me is always an
incredibly inspiring thing so
Thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always, I will see you
... in the next video!
Bye Bye! (voice cracking)
(cough laughter) oh god the puberty.